we're here not to discuss transportation
but to discuss education in 1971 with
just over a dozen african-american
lawmakers serving in congress
the congressional black caucus was
formed to help amplify their voice
in an institution that wasn't always
welcoming
even in the house of representatives
black folks just was not expected and
indeed
wasn't wanted at 90 years old former new
york representative charles rangel is
one of the last
surviving founders of the group you
actually came
up with the name congressional black
caucus just the name
we all had a common mission and a common
goal to prove the
quality of life for america and
especially minority americans
rangel shirley chisholm charles diggs
and the other original members
quickly met resistance when former
president nixon
refused to meet with them the courtesy
should be extended to
us when it was abundantly clear that he
did not intend to meet we then said that
we would not attend the state of the
union message
after boycotting nixon's address they
finally got the meeting
putting the cbc on the map and opening
the halls of power
the caucus as a whole of course was
gravely concerned with their core
nonpartisan principle
no permanent friends no permanent
enemies just
permanent interest shirley's with me
today california congresswoman barbara
lee still has shirley chisholm's pearls
she worked on her 1972 presidential
campaign and later as chief of staff for
ron dellums
learning firsthand from two of the
caucus's original members that's how i
got involved in politics it was just
quite a remarkable
moment for me as a young black woman
raising two kids as a single mom to see
how the congressional black caucus and
his founders
really did step out there and fight
for the african-american community
historically a democratic power center
cbc members were the first to draft
legislation
to make dr martin luther king's birthday
a national holiday
we will act the caucus was also at the
forefront pushing for sanctions against
south africa's apartheid government
it was the first time a reagan veto of a
major piece of legislation has been
overridden
earning the caucus a reputation as the
conscience of the congress
that was a big moment in the cbc's
history
because it began to influence foreign
policy and showed how we could be
finally on the right side of history
more recently the cbc led the effort to
pass police reform through the house
in honor of george floyd the justice and
policing
act is a bill for human rights it is an
incredible time to be serving in
congress
in the midst of a national reckoning on
racial injustice
congresswoman ayanna presley says the
cbc allows newer members like her
to learn from mentors like lee the power
and impact of this representation is not
just in that it plants the seeds
of aspiration but how it shows up in our
policies
you know we have snapped today because
shirley chisholm
made it so because she brought a
different perspective
as a black woman on the issue of hunger
that's the beauty
of the caucus ohio congresswoman joyce
beatty chairs the cbc as it enters
its 50th year do you still feel like you
are
waging some of the same battles from 50
years ago
i think we are certainly waging some of
the battles but i can also tell you
not 50 years ago but 10 years ago if you
would have told me
that we would have had a black president
of the united states
i would not have thought that we had
made that much progress
and our member kamala harris now vice
president
so we have a lot to be proud of